[Music]
germany's covet infections are now
higher than ever
and the numbers keep growing
that's despite a relatively high
vaccination rate almost 70 percent of
germans are fully vaccinated against the
virus
one problem is breakthrough infections
where the disease manages to bypass the
jab
the only consolation for the vaccinated
is that severe illness is rare
i'm ben fazeland good to have you along
concern over a possible fourth wave has
german health officials pushing for a
rapid rollout of boosters before winter
also of concern a significant number of
the fully vaccinated among those new
cases
dw's tessa valetta spoke to one sufferer
of a so-called breakthrough infection
even simple things are still difficult
for leo bahusburma
two weeks after her covert 19 infection
the 30 year old still struggles to get
back to our old life
normally i go running every other day
and do a lot of other sports and
exercise but i put all that on hold for
now simply because i notice my breathing
is still a bit tight when i climb stairs
i notice i have to do it slowly i have
to catch my breath a lot and i have to
take breaks
leo bar still tries to get more rest
than usual
finding her way back into her job as a
surgeon is difficult
she contracted covet 19 despite being
fully vaccinated for over two weeks she
was sick at home
i did not expect to have such a severe
illness i thought someone like me at 30
with no pre-existing conditions would
just lie in bed for two or three days
and relax the rest of the time in
quarantine but it was definitely not
like that for me i was very very sick
for two weeks
more and more breakthrough infections
are being reported in germany
among around 55 million fully vaccinated
people around 118 000 had a breakthrough
infection
this number is also visible in intensive
care units
according to current figures around 10
percent of people in icus between 18 and
59 are fully vaccinated it is even 30
percent for over 60 year olds
see
however that doesn't mean that
vaccination doesn't work if you look at
the number of breakthrough infections
you see that they still represent the
minority although the number of
vaccinated people is much higher
from this ratio alone you see that a
vaccination still protects really well
leova's vaccination was over seven
months ago which could be the reason for
her infection
despite her experience she would get
vaccinated again
i have in no way lost faith in
vaccination i'll definitely continue to
be vaccinated against all infectious
diseases i believe the course of my
disease would have been much more
serious without being vaccinated and it
protects you from dying of infectious
diseases or from suffering a severe bout
even
for love
leoba now takes everything step by step
and she's hopeful that she'll fully
recover soon
and let's take you through this topic
step by step with sheri khalsa head of
epidemiology at the helmholtz center for
infection research or hzi in
braunschweig germany
tell our viewers why we're seeing more
vaccinated germans catching covert and
getting sick first of all
well first we must
clearly see and say
that this is an exception and it is very
few cases that do get a disease a severe
disease
even though they have been vaccinated
twice so it's really an exception it
proves that the vaccine is really very
protective
extraordinary protective i would compare
i would say comparison with other
vaccines
especially if we look into the intensive
care units it's almost a rarity to see
patients that have
require intensive care and that have
been vaccinated fully at the same time
we also see that for those patients
where this does happen
it's mostly patients who have been
vaccinated quite some time ago very
early and patients who have an age of
over 65 and that is not astonishing
because the immunity vanishes over time
and also elderly people respond not as
well to the vaccine as younger people
and that is why we recommend a booster
vaccine for the elderly
okay um so when you say it it starts
disappearing over time immunity you're
talking about what a half year aren't
you uh because that's why authorities
here including the german health
minister has got is booster
that is correct and i believe
we should focus our vaccination
activities to those people who have not
received any vaccine at all especially
those among the highways groups they are
still a relevant amount
still a relevant amount of people in the
high-risk people who have not received
any vaccine
and those are the majority who make the
cases in the intensive care units
and secondly
to offer booster vaccine for the elderly
who are these high risk groups
those are people over the age of 65
those are people with other
preconditions with chronic diseases and
immune suppressive diseases who tend to
develop a more severe disease after
infection
so what's this mean are we going to see
more hospital admissions as winter
approaches here in germany
yes unfortunately this is going to be
the case we can
keep that lower and we can try to
control that
by several measures
one is that we try to vaccinate those
who need to be vaccinated and that we
convince those who didn't get vaccine
yet to really get the vaccine
first
second to make especially sure that
those people who take care of vulnerable
people like nurses in elderly homes that
they be fully vaccinated third that the
elderly who have already received a
vaccine earlier this year that they
receive a booster vaccine and third not
to forget that one to keep up the
hygiene measures wearing face masks
keeping up general hygiene measures
especially in areas where vulnerable
people live like elderly homes and
hospitals so we're not going to be able
to throw away those masks anytime soon
but tell us about the current
vaccination right i mentioned it before
of 70
in germany of fully vaccinated uh
residents here or citizens here is that
enough to get through this winter in
good shape
um
i think i would like to answer it a
different way
it is more important to get the
vulnerable people vaccinated hundred
percent than getting the full back
population vaccinated eighty percent
so
uh we do see that the complete
vaccination coverage in the overall
population is important but more
important in my view is getting the
vulnerable people
very well vaccinated and especially
getting those vaccinated to take care of
those vulnerable people speaking of
medical personnel nurses and so on in
elderly homes and that's more important
than than a third shot a booster
vaccination
yes definitely
you know if we still have a relevant
amount of people
in the vulnerable population not
vaccinated it's more important to get
them vaccinated first rather than giving
booster vaccine to younger people who
don't have a very high risk of
developing severe disease at all
but they also have the possibility of
passing on the disease don't they
yes but
the
highest priority for us in the
vaccination is to prevent severe disease
that is the main aim of the vaccine
how well would you say the health system
in germany is prepared in case there are
more severe cases again
that is difficult to say because
in general i would say it is well
repaired it's always a balance because
you need to then de-prioritize other
healthcare activities
operations that may be postponed
operations that may not be so urgent but
that normally require intensive care and
the follow-up of the operation so you
need to prioritize and make a choice of
course if you have your acute acutely
ill person of a respiratory infection
you need to provide intensive care units
for that person
what we see now is an increasing number
of patients in the intensive care unit
so that is worrisome
and therefore we need to hurry up to get
those who have not received vaccines yet
to get to give them vaccine
thank you very much for being on the
show today
my pleasure
and a simple but pertinent question for
our science correspondent derek williams
now
why are vaccines still not universally
available
many of the experts i've read tend to
talk about two different aspects of this
issue um the first is vaccine shortages
which are caused by
factors rooted mostly in logistics for
instance
um the fact that production of any
medical product is going to be limited
by bottlenecks in upstream feedstocks of
the ingredients that go into it
it simply takes time to ramp up the
entire production chain
of these highly specialized vaccines to
the kinds of scales that we need to
fight a global pandemic
the challenges surrounding vaccine
transport and distribution
also contribute to shortages
but at least the vaccine shortage
problem is theoretically solvable right
i mean we just have to get production up
to speed and we're doing that but
the same can't be said
for other factors that have gotten in
the way of universal availability
they're what the experts mean
when they talk about
vaccine inequities
the program that was supposed to prevent
them
the kovacs initiative has struggled from
the beginning
to meet distribution targets for poorer
countries not only because
the logistics are hard but because
wealthier countries
quickly snapped up nearly all of the
available stocks for their own
populations
according to the who
vaccine manufacturers are currently
churning out around
one and a half billion doses of vaccine
every month so
the issue
has now become a lot less about
shortages and a lot more about ongoing
lopsided allocation
and that's continuing even though we
know
that the fastest way to end the pandemic
is to make vaccines
universally available
[Music]
and the pandemic has made it harder for
the most vulnerable to get medical help
even as they may need it more than ever
this bus aims to change that it travels
around the serbian capital belgrade to
help the homeless it offers them a
chance for a hot shower and medical
attention
homelessness is a relatively recent
problem in serbia and some of the
homeless say the pandemic has made the
problem worse by making it impossible
for them to return to the places they're
from
stay safe and see you again soon
[Music]
[Music]
you